[Musique]
au sommaire de ce parent 78 portrait
véronique chaplin présidente de sos
gazelle et fondatrice de tiebreak ou
quand le golf se met au service du
caritatif
gros plan sur l' open tv 78 qui a eu
lieu le 24 mars dernier et enfin conseil
matériel avec raphaël halipré
[Musique]
non
nous sommes au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines à mes côtés
véronique chaplin une chaîne et
deviennent alors véronique et vous avez
créé le tiebreak il y à 26 ans oui
expliquez-nous pourquoi est bien petit
break déjà alors le tiebreak c'est un
rassemblement de sportifs de haut niveau
de toutes les disciplines sur un terrain
neutre au profit de l'association sos
gazelle et pourquoi l'avoir créée il ya
26 ans justement alors en fait moi je
démarré ma carrière professionnelle chez
nike
j'étais une passionnée de sport et j'ai
pu constater que le sport permettait
vraiment l'ouverture sur le monde mais
je travaillais aussi bien avec des
sportifs prestigieux dans le tennis
comme agassi des grands footballeurs
mais aussi d'autres champions qui était
moins connu et j'ai voulu mettre tous
ces champions à égalité sur terrain
neutre ya des sportifs peut-être qu'ils
vous ont parlé du cibray qui vous a
donné l'idée du tiebreak où c'est
vraiment votre propre idée
alors en fait il ya un champion d'europe
de triathlon qui arrive dans mon bureau
qui me dit verrou je n'en peux plus ça
fait dix ans que j'ai pas manger une
frite que j'ai pas de petite copine et
c'est un mec super humainement et ça
fait tilt dans ma tête et je me suis dit
mais en fait chaque sport et dans son
côté toi tu es joueuse de tennis et une
rencontre pas les autres champions de
discipline
donc il faut que tu rassemble tous ces
champions sur terrain neutre et que tu
crées un événement multisport donc c'est
sur un terrain de golf 1 que ça se passe
le tiebreak pourquoi un terrain de golf
est ce que c'est un sport peut être
vecteur de certaines valeurs qui nous
sont chères
oui bah le golf à l'époque en 1992 ce
n'était pas du tout démocratique et je
me suis dit je vais pouvoir faire
découvrir le golf au plus grand nombre
et notamment l'état de sportif je pense
à yannick noah laurent blanc à l'époque
qui des sportifs qui connaissait le golf
quand même vendu qu'aux nôtres qui
n'était pas que je n'étais pas content
du tout déjà j'avais une astuce c'est
qu'à côté de la compétition tiebreak je
faisais une initiation et là en loucedé
il s'entraînait pour essayer de faire
des bons résultats chez vous ce soir de
manière discrète de leur vie au tiebreak
et l'année d'après comme ce sont des
compétiteurs dans l'âme y revenait et là
en fait c'était très très fort il avait
découvert eux est il vraiment ça c'est
devenu l'amour du golfe pour certains il
y en a certains vraiment qu'ils sont mis
à jouer devant tous les jours google
fait suite au tiebreak tous les jours et
quand je vois des gens comme boghossian
qui sont aujourd'hui négatifs comme noah
comme alain roche comme antoine
kombouaré comme des rugbymans brian
saimone mannix qui a gagné le tiebreak
ici au golf national
mais parce que le tiebreak s'est joué au
golf national une fois oui tout à fait
en fait au départ en fait c'est une
histoire d'amour quand même avec roland
garros il faut bien le dire moi j'étais
joueuse de tennis et au départ
l'histoire dont le nom du petit break
c'est le jeune montre le type du golfe
et le tie break du tennis en fait j'ai
été voir le directeur de roland garros
et je lui dis vous êtes en concurrence
les quatre tournois du grand chelem ce
serait top d'organiser un service aux
joueurs et de les faire jouer au golf
et c'est pour ça que ça s'appelle le
tiebreak roland garros et pour revenir
au col nationale oui ça s'est joué en
2006 avec la victoire de l'international
des all blacks qui a joué moins 6 sur ce
parcours qui est énorme énorme parce que
c'est l'un des plus compliqués au monde
alors le golf national mais également
d'autres golfs dans les yvelines on
participe au tiebreak oui oui ben ali
l'idée en fait c'est de faire découvrir
aux jeunes et aux sportifs de haut
niveau
un maximum de golf en france et à
l'étranger pendant le tiebreak roland
garros bien sûr en ile de france et donc
l'année dernière c'était a bêtement
cette année c'est qu'au goal de la
vaucouleurs mardi 22 mai et donc on leur
fait découvrir oui un maximum de deux
super parcours et dans le national il
est également une vocation associative
vraiment cette journée vous faites venir
des jeunes des enfants de deux trappes
on va y arriver en étant virage alors
des jeunes de trappes notamment cette
année
oui bah en fait si tu veux dès que j'ai
vu cet engouement la première année en
1992 avec la victoire de vitas
gerulaitis on avait le champion de
france de golf une aura les médias et
c'est un succès fou je me suis dit ça
doit pas s'arrêter à un rassemblement de
sportifs faut qu'il y ait une cause
qu'ils soient plus grande celle des
enfants et donc j'ai aidé des
associations sportives de haut niveau
jusqu'à ce que le basketteur boris diaw
de 10,0 tu crées ta propre sauce parce
que t'es trop fédératrice donc on se
mettra derrière derrière toi et donc on
a créé sos gazelles qui grandit grandit
grandit depuis depuis 13 ans maintenant
et l'idée c'est de développer
l'éducation par le sport et la santé en
france et en afrique et donc tous les
ans sur le golf on est à peu près la
seule âme est un bordel comme ça à côté
de la librairie ans à ba c'est de la
folie
à côté la compet de golf un ring de boxe
une piste d'athlétisme un terrain de
tennis on peut se dire qu'un jour le
voilà on à vis des jeunes des yvelines
trappe cette année comme tu l'as dit
versailles terrain mais ils sont
encadrés par les champions du monde
médaillé olympique et et c'est l'éclaté
t'as les grands qui viennent en
fin d'après-midi et rejoint les jeunes
sur le ring de boxe en général
voilà alors du coup comment ça se passe
avec les jeunes quand ils voient ces
grands sportifs en face d'eux abbas et
les yeux illuminés plein de bonheur des
rires mais surtout on les suit nous
d'année en année et ils ont des
souvenirs qui sont gravés dans leur
mémoire de manière absolument incroyable
puis ce qui est bien aussi c'est que
quand tu vois ces grands champions qui
sont des vrais enfants et qu'ils ont
aussi des étoiles qui brillent dans les
yeux basse etc c'est que du bonheur
vraiment que du bonheur c'est du
gagnant-gagnant vraiment totalement mais
franchement ils viennent avec grand
plaisir
ils participent ils s'amusent ils font
les pitres tout temps passant des
messages sérieux sur ya le golf il ya le
sport en général mais il ya l'éducation
la santé tu vois il passe des messages
de vos gamins d'être ponctuel de bien
s'alimenter de bien respirer et salé
camille s'en souviennent pas ce que ça
vient de la bouche d'un champion du
monde ou d'un médailles olympiques et
vous avez des retours ou pas d'aider des
jeunes justement quelques années plus
tard qui qui viennent vous voir
véronique chaplin c'était extraordinaire
je m'en souviens comme ce mail car il ya
des trucs géniaux c'est que bon comme tu
lis et on fait aussi des choses beaucoup
au sénégal en ile de france et il ya des
petits enfants qu'on a qu'on a connu à
5-6 ans quand aujourd'hui 18 ans et qui
viennent de me demander de faire des
stages qui ont super bien réussi dans la
vie mais surtout quand des valeurs
d'humanisme des changes et qui veulent
rendre à travers ce stage ce qu'ils ont
appris avec sos gazelle susciter les
vocations bas un petit peu c'est génial
les petits enfants autour de moi c'est
très sympa légalement une grande partie
importante en dans le tiebreak c'est la
vente aux enchères qui se déroule tous
les soirs qu'est ce que ces nouveaux
sorts les enchères caritative ya pas de
petit break bah si tu veux en fait
chaque sportif de haut niveau en plus
d'être présent dans la bonne humeur
apporte un objet mythique est justement
les objets sont derrière oui mais
j'étais à ma portée parce que quand
achetés renchérit ça va coûter cher j'ai
économisé toute l'année pourquoi on
rétablit un intérêt alors qu'elle a
complètement les gens font des dons
alors
la boxe la boxe dit super souliers mbaye
double champion du monde de boxe qui eux
n'ont pas eu accès et qui vient de
monter en plus une ouvrir une salle à
dakar c'est absolument génial là pendant
l'association la raquette de yannick
noah vainqueur de roland garros est
signée bien sûr il ya toujours psg et
marseille qui se bagarrent tu vois donc
on a le on avait raté on en aura
d'autres verra-t-il italien devient
urgent en ligne est toujours assignée tu
as face à lui notre ami valère germain
ou alors germain qui joue aujourd'hui à
l'om maintenant inquiétait qu'elle
allait ce mot là qu'on va le prendre
justement le vaio 2 de valère germain
on a un coût supérieur au nôtre ami
chabal au niveau rugby qui va nous
apporter un maillot super alors tous les
ans aussi il ya le t-shirt fétiche
tu vois de l'année et puis partir
obligatoirement avec ça c'est obligé
selongey de l'année suivante
non mais attends quand tu sais que 100 %
des dons sont remis le soir même à
l'association pour les enfants
quand tu sais qu'on a on a des centaines
d'enfants ce qui sont scolarisés et qui
pratique le sport grâce à ces enchères
si on a envie et puis il faut préciser à
la télé que dans le cadre de des dons à
l'association ça la france a fait un
truc très bien c'est qu'il ya une
récupération de 66% du montant
et ça faut pas hésiter à le dire quand
les gens font un don de 1000 euros ça
leur coûte 300 euros
alors du coup qui peut participer aux
enchères écoute les enchères s'est
ouvert au public les gens se présentent
voilà ils viennent nous contacter sur
facebook et en général ça c'est combien
maillot de marque on verra si par
exemple à bas les objets ça va de 200
euros jusqu'à cinq six mille euros
il faut bien qu'on me disait est
exactement alors je crois qu'il ya une
tradition chaque année au tiebreak est
ce qu'on peut nous la présenter mais oui
c'est le concours peut-il spécial roland
garros bat tout simplement si tu veux on
remplit on remplaça balle de golf un la
balle de tennis
mais la balle de tennis le plus gros lot
jugon c'est puissant c'est plus gros il
n'y a aucune trajectoire ce qui fait que
tous nos amis pro de golf qui viennent
d'ailleurs tous les ans bénévolement
faut les remercier parce que son fou
parce que chacun à trois essais les
gamins les sportifs et néophytes et ceux
qui gagnent
tu vas voir c'est toujours les débutants
ont testé à attester
[Musique]
super tir 1 véronique mais je suis la
reine du go qu'est ce que tu veux je
peux pas être champion puisque il me
prend tout mon temps à l'organisation à
la sauce mais l'année prochaine je joue
petit break
merci beaucoup véronique pour cette
session mais toutes ces explications par
rapport au tiebreak merci à toi milk est
donc ça sera le 22 mai mardi 22 mai
rendez-vous goal de la vaucouleurs tous
golfeurs et non colfer et puis faites
des économies pour enchérir sur des lots
mais magnifique mythique et qui vont en
plus prendre de la valeur et qui vont
rendre des centaines d'enfants heureux
faut pas l'oublier
voyez et moi je vais économiser pour
participent aux anges je compte bien sûr
véronique le secteur bien l'om on peut
le dire on peut le dire on peut le dire
d'accord à bientôt à l'inertie merci
beaucoup
[Musique]
au terme d'un hiver qui n'en finissait
pas le samedi 24 mars jour de la sainte
adhémar est à marquer d'une pierre
blanche
d'abord parce que comme par miracle le
soleil était de la partie
ensuite parce que c'était le jour du
deuxième open tv 78 organisé sur le
parcours de l'aigle et de l'albatros
celui de la future ryder cup du golf
national du soleil cent trente
participants beaucoup de sponsors et
donc de cadeaux bref selon laurent
mazaury président de tv 78 et philippe
pilate au directeur adjoint du golf
national
une vraie réussite
[Musique]
tu as en compagnie de leurs hommages au
riz président de tv 78 et de philippe
plateau directeur adjoint du golf
national et du site du golf national
sommes le 24 mars et a lieu aujourd'hui
a eu lieu aujourd'hui le 2e open tv 78
saint quentin en yvelines
laurent c'était encore et de réussite
puisqu'on est au soir de cette
compétition dont on peut le dire une
grande réussite beaucoup de participants
une météorologie favorable des
partenaires actifs
je pense des joueurs qui ont été très
contents un golf préparer manière
parfaite malgré des conditions
météorologiques de la semaine passée qui
était très difficile je rappelle que la
semaine dernière nous avions encore de
la neige à saint quentin
là il a fait un soleil splendide quand
on voit l'état du parcours aujourd'hui
ça m'énerve ce parcours peut accueillir
de grandes compétitions sans subir des
affres de la météorologie
justement philippe c'est vrai que
bruxelles parcours là il y avait les
laits compétition avait lieu et sur
l'albatros et sur l'aigle
mais sur le parcours qui va accueillir
la la ryder cup
on voit que c'est un parcours qui voit
là il est prêt quoi mais je pense que
oui effectivement le parcours est prêt
les travaux ont été engagés on a fermé
le parcours pendant dix mois il ya deux
ans et maintenant on voit le résultat
des la qualité des travaux qui ont été
faits par notamment par rapport au
drainage avec cet hiver les conditions
qui ont été difficiles depuis le mois de
novembre et c'est vrai qu'on se rend
compte que ses pertes de l'année
on pourrait limites dans quinze jours
pour accueillir et organiser un open de
france
c'est formidable alors il ya une
certaine complicité jalousie entre entre
le golf national la fédération mais le
golf national et et tv 78 et saint
quentin en yvelines et vinolas c'est ce
que j'allais dire complicité entre tv 78
nationale mais entre saint quentin
deviner le boeuf nationale d'abord parce
que saint quentin en yvelines est une
terre de golf national et également deux
autres god de typologies différentes à
une volonté également d'intégrer le golf
auprès des du plus grand nombre puisque
un vrai travail était effectué avec les
scolaires et les enfants et les écoles
mais également les entreprises et donc
on peut dire aujourd'hui cinq autres
villes est une terre de golf grâce à la
fédération française de golf au golf
national
atv 78 bien sûr mais à saint quentin en
yvelines également
rappelons que paul armitage vous le
rappeliez fait une émission en anglais
sur telos 70 il y aura une ride un open
l'année prochaine une tv 150 andy greene
oui tout à fait parce que c'est la
volonté de tv 78 d'inscrire cet
événement dans le cadre des événements
récurrents mais c'est également la
volonté j'ai l'accord déjà des élus et
du président de 50 villes pour qu'il y
ait une édition numéro 3 édition numéro
3 qui je l'espère cette fois ci
permettra également aux entreprises est
présente
on avait prévu des mails soient avec
nous cette année pour des raisons tout
simplement d'organisation on a souhaité
qu'ils ont cru se rapproche d'une
opération il ya la chambre de commerce
et d'industrie qui peut un mot on va
dire une ryder cup des entreprises donc
on l'a décroché de l'opération de l'open
télé 70 et et saint quentin mais l'année
prochaine nous aurons les entreprises
donc nous serons sur deux journées
'l'annonce par avance philippe barbeau
justement sur le parcours de l'albatros
il va fermer fin mai alors le parcours
non non non le parcours en fait on va le
faire mais le 2 septembre au soir c'est
à dire qu'on va avoir la capacité de
pouvoir jouer le parcours jusqu à peine
trois semaines avant les premiers
matches cela de la ryder cup donc ça
c'est une première parce que
habituellement les parcours ferme au
moins six mois avant ce qui veut dire
que pour les personnes qui veulent
vraiment vivre une expérience ryder cup
jusqu'au bout du bout et on fera
certainement une opération spéciale les
1er et 2 septembre pour fêter le
dernière partie qui jouera qui jouent à
la main le parcours là bas trois savants
la raideur donc venez nombreux cet été
juillet août pour voilà vivre une
expérience formidable sur le parcours
une rêveuse et venait jouer sur ses pas
pour sublimer
prenez vous pour des champions merci
beaucoup l'euro mazauric merci beaucoup
philippe pilate haut et donc à l'année
prochaine à l'an prochain alors prochain
[Musique]
parmi les sponsors de cette compétition
il donc de golf maroc.com qui faisait
gagner des séjours au maroc
hugo desnoyer le boucher le plus célèbre
de france et ambassadeur de la ryder cup
mais aussi arnaud rock ambassadeurs des
sens que les golfeurs qu'il fait goûter
ses produits de luxe cavia whisky et
cigares ont appris à connaître une des
grandes attractions de cette compétition
tu es 78 c'est le stand d'arnaud rock on
va s'attarder sens arnaud qui est de
plus en plus présent d'ailleurs dans les
compétitions de golf on va savoir
pourquoi alors c'est un formidable de
voir il ya donc goutte d alcool
magnifique et des whisky et des poireaux
voir parler mais c'est vrai arnaud que
vous êtes de plus en plus présent dans
les compétitions de golf pour pourquoi
c'est un univers que j'ai créée depuis
depuis cinq ans maintenant où j'ai voulu
faire partager les produits les produits
que je source tout au long de l'année
on est sûr sur le caviar on est sur des
spiritueux on est une touche d'épicerie
salle et d'épiceries sucré ah oui avec
des produits de luxe sont des produits
de 2.8 ali téléthon il est premium
produit et c'est vrai que ça va bien
avec ça va c'est bien avec le golf c'est
un univers qui se collent bien il ya une
petite touche cydia rien petites touches
alcool une petite touche gourmande
il fait bon vivre les golfeurs m
appréciez cet après après l'émoi est
également surtout et avant tout comment
vous est venue à faire ce cursus
classique école hôtelière
restauration parisienne un petit peu
d'étrangers et au fil du temps j'ai été
baigné dans le produit je suis fils
d'artisans pâtissiers boulangers
d'accord
[Musique]
aussi des arrière grands parents dans le
commerce est en fait je crois que c'est
dans l'adn quoi tout simplement donc on
a envie de partager on a envie de goûter
on a envie de les changer et ce qui est
intéressant c'est cette source et le
produit c'est d'aller oui de savoir d'où
il vient et alors il ya des produits
absolument fantastique et justement
comment vous comment vous les repérer
vous même et quand vous comment vous
choisissez ce que vous mettez en vente
il ya des choses sur lesquelles que j'ai
rencontrés durant mon cursus
professionnel donc ça c'est d'un premier
point puis le deuxième point aujourd'hui
j'ai j'essaie de volonté d'aller
chercher d'avoir un coup d'avancé et
c'est la magie des rencontres
donc c'est l'ami qui me dit j'ai un
producteur en aveyron qu'il fait kiffer
des terrines de cochon de tulle noir
j'ai un spiritueux comme michel couvreur
qui est qui est une très belle histoire
là par exemple de whisky français c'est
un distillat qui vient des choristes il
dit ces rapatriés en bourgogne avec des
fûts de xérès qui viennent d'espagne qui
ont une vraie richesse un adn est en
fait on les fait vieillir en bourgogne
et ça donne des whiskys d'une gamme
alors il ya à peu près une douzaine de
whisky dans cette gamme et c'est la
magie de justement de l'adn du bois qui
va donner c'est le résultat
je dis ça parce que c'est ces salles à
l'attrait de ce que vous faites c'est
que l'on va découvrir des produits qu on
voit là sauf souffre être un grand
connaisseur on trouvera pas ailleurs
on le trouve dans les manifs et bien sûr
ils sont tous sous moi l'idée c'est de
trouver en fait voilà il ya eu après il
ya encore d'autres produits que
certainement que je n'ai pas encore
rencontré il ya des choses sur
lesquelles je ne
me détacherai jamais parce que parce que
j'aime ce produit là je sais que ça
plaît et puis de temps en temps bailly
les petits coups de coeur il ya des
petites choses éphémères qui qui font
côté surprise si on attend aussi pris 70
dates à 75 et sur les golfs parents
francis et étrangers maintenant belgique
luxembourg vous êtes de plus en plus
demandés voilà plus demandés web puisque
je pense que j'apporte une petite
dix animations touche de plaisir de
savoir y est j'ai mes propres clients
mais
mes amis joueurs qui qui me disent
arnaud qu'est ce qu'il y a ajouté que ce
qui est nouveau
donc là c'est un vrai gâchis sur
internet j'ai mon site internet
l'ambassade et redescend ce point comme
on retrouve essentiellement l'ensemble
de mes produits la gamme caviar les
spiritueux et cette épicerie fine qui là
aussi est un est un puits sans fond
voilà alors il faut pas trop il faut pas
trop que les laisons du 16 et du qualiac
aviez on a le droit à une libération et
puis la fumée avec beaucoup de
modération en plus simplement de faire
c'est cette petite ces petites remarques
c'est la dégustation dont nouvelle
dégustation est uniquement sur la
dégustation
et puis des gens qui veulent acheter
pour chez eux et ils peuvent ils peuvent
le faire mais après je suis pas maître
de sa 6e passe après il reste une belle
saison et l'a donc toute l'année vous
êtes on peut vous voir dans les
compétitions sur le toutou l'école de
france et aussi à l'étranger une bonne
partie par treize candidates 70 dates ça
représente de jargon pas une des
compétitions de sociétés d des sociétés
qui et d'événementiel également co
organisent des détours des sociétés là
pour le coup et puis ça peut être la
compétition du dimanche dans un club
privé si vous aviez besoin voilà et ça
fait plaisir c'est vrai plaisir aux gens
qu'il faut les compétitions et puis ils
peuvent ramener des magnifiques produits
chez eux
merci beaucoup avait à peine fait
plaisir
autre sponsor olivier looten l'homme qui
a inventé eagle cette formule qui vous
permet de jouer sur un parcours même si
vous n'avez qu'une heure devant vous
animez d'hôtel vous êtes un des sponsors
de la compétition de de t'aimer 78 vous
êtes le cofondateur de eagle est ce que
vous pouvez nous dire en quelques mots
ce qui est illégal et à quoi ça sert à
qui s'adresse absolument leur gueule
c'est le premier service de paiement du
golfe au trou notre objectif est d'aider
les joueurs à jouer plus souvent
notamment les golfeurs entre 25 et 50
ans qui n'ont plus le temps de jouer
régulièrement la fin exactement pour les
qualifiant d' usher de pression
familiale de famille ou de goût de
travail donc c'est une application qui
est gratuite que vous téléchargez sur
les stores et qui vous permet de
d'aller jouer sur un parcours et de ne
payer que les trous que vous allez jouer
réellement le temps de jouer 5 3
semaines et fait rage après cinq trous
exactement et alors il ya combien de
golf en france sur lesquelles on peut
voir 70 dont galp national ou même
aujourd'hui
chaque semaine on a de nouvelles de
monde c'est vraiment je pense un nouveau
moyen de consommer le golf est surtout
un moyen de s'adapter au mode de vie
moderne
le golf est un sport anciens qui ne
s'est pas adapté dans le temps nous on
essaye de l'adapter et de la porter à la
dimension des joueurs c'est vrai qu'il
18 trous bientôt ça sera peut-être
souvenu
en tout cas c'est vrai que c'est une
adaptation à un mode de vie moderne quoi
exactement
et on paye notre nombre de trophées
et aujourd'hui les joueurs nos joueurs
jouent en moyenne sept trous 1h15 plutôt
solitaire jusqu'à présent et enfin
journée après le travail voilà c'est
bien vrai que dès qu'on a un petit
moment on peut dire exactement sur le
site aux réserves et comme ça et après
et après on compare avec l'application
on peut directement avec l'application
comme hubert lambert
voilà de l'application va calculer le
nombre de trucs vous jouez et vous payez
directement sur l'application
c'est un peu le père du g puis ça
s'appelle eagle et c'est olivier hôtel
merci beaucoup merci patron
[Musique]
bonjour aujourd'hui je vais vous
expliquer comment choisir sa tête de
club et pourquoi d'été deux clubs sont
plus ou moins faciles à jouer si on
prend donc la tête de club qui est très
bon des rentes pour la jouabilité on va
voir des responsables de clubs sont déjà
plus ou moins films en général les têtes
de clubs fine comme celle ci en exemple
- centre de gravité assez aux dans la
tête donc vont produire des trajectoires
basse la difficulté au début est temps
de lever la balle on va prendre de tête
de club où on va alléger la partie haute
mettre du poids dans la partie basse ce
qui permet d'avoir un son de gravité
plus bas d'un pub et d'avoir des flashs
plus élevé c'est très important
ensuite on parle beaucoup dans les clubs
de golf de aymeric de moment d'inertie
qu'est ce que le hand oui on regarde
comment un club réagit lors qu'ils ne
l'aient pas frappé en plein centre ont
fait pas lui qui pilotait parce qu'on
est assez en pointe allons il allait
perdre de la puissance
je suis un club qui n'a aucune
répartition de masse comme celui ci
c'est un cap très difficile à jouer
la zone d'impact idéal va être très
réduite
lorsque vous allez des centres et de
cette zone tout de suite ça va perdre
beaucoup d'énergie et beaucoup de vols
de balle si on prend un club comme
celui-ci où on s'aperçoit on a enlevé
donc le poids du haut pour le descendre
donc une semaine un petit peu plus large
c'est ce qui permet d'avoir un sens des
réalités bas mais surtout ici on a des
matériaux qui sont beaucoup plus lourds
en pointe et en talons du club ceci
permet de donner de l' équilibre au club
ce qu'on appelle de l'inertie donc mon
club va - piloter lorsque je vais te des
centres et ma frappe c'est ce qui
permettra donc aux joueurs de pouvoir ne
pas trop perdre sur un coût qui va être
légèrement décentré donc ces clubs s'ils
sont beaucoup plus préconisé pour des
joueurs débutants ou en phase de
progression très fort joueur pourra
jouer ce type de club parce que lui son
centrage sera plein centre et donc il
pourra travailler aussi sa trajectoire
un peu différemment maintenant il est
vraiment très conne ise dans un premier
temps de passer sur des clubs facile à
jouer avec du poids sur les côtés une
semaine large ce qui permet de lever la
balle est d'avoir au moins de
déperdition sur les coudes et centrer
handball je vois ici là je vais auteur
très dommage donc en général les très
bons joueurs ont une bonne vitesse et un
angle d'attaqué assez direct sur la
balle donc ont des capacités de faire
voler la balle donc n'ont pas besoin
d'aller chercher cet e-mail large mais
au contraire ils veulent des semelles
plus fine pour pouvoir plus travailler
les effets dans la balle même si on peut
aussi à travailler et c'est peut-être là
on travaillera encore plus ici il est
pas qu'ici on aura de très très bonnes
sensations ici on va enlever un peu de
sensation pour donner de la tolérance le
sait un peu jeune le jeu pardon du chat
et de la souris sur la tête de clubs
plus mon club va être tolérant entre
guillemets moins il y aura de sensations
et plus je vais aller chercher une
sensation moins j'aurai de tolérance on
peut tout de faire le bon compromis
en tout cas lorsqu'on débute de prendre
les clubs facile à jouer pour avoir un
maximum de réussite
[Musique]
merci de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
très vite pour un nouveau numéro 2 par
[Musique]